voilà j'ai entendu qu'il y avait
beaucoup de conflits entre le québec et
le reste du canada et je trouve que ça
devrait pas exister dans un si beau pays
alors voilà dans cette chanson je
voulais m'adresser justement à tous ces
canadiens en dehors du québec et
j'espère qu'ils m'entendent rond
[Applaudissements]
votre pays est magnifique le canada ça
fait rêver
petit paradis en ami route avec ses lacs
et ses forêts offrant à tous ses
habitants
la meilleure des qualités de vie en plus
de tous les continents
vous êtes le peuple le plus gentil ça
fait des années cependant que vous vous
placez seulement deuxième meilleur pays
du monde
juste après la suisse c'est la honte mes
amis il faut pour de vent ont de la
place que
pour être la plus belle des nations il
n'y a qu'une chose à faire vous le savez
dégagez moi tous ces québécois dre
[ __ ] qu'est ce que c'est que cet arrêt
des bâtards anglo franco je ne sais quoi
que la france a juste et carré
comme une mère qui aurait planqué à plus
de six mille bornes sur la carte ces
gosses consanguins non désirées et c'est
vous qui avez
haarde les plaines d'abraham en 1716
rookie ressorti gagnant une vente de
niaiseux comme trophée comme vous vous
êtes bien bénite et depuis mille de
casser les glandes pour vous respectez
leur français alors nous mêmes nous pour
les comprendre on a besoin de sous
titres en anglais
[Musique]
attache ta tuque quétigny tout ça ne se
dit pas bande de beats et le niveau de
français chez nous d'un bébé singe
trisomique puis s'il parlait si bien
français pourquoi leur parti
s'appellerait pq alors qu'en france en
fait le musée du papier toilette
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant ils veulent l'indépendance de
mira pays en puissance et c'est quoi ce
n'est qu'au bout 7 18
il ouvrait plus tôt
de toute façon vous comprendrez
vite votre connerie quand vous tirez ce
soir on attaque la poutine avec les
russes vous compareront ici
il dégage et les faux pas tarder car ils
vont s'ils voulaient garder continuer à
s'opposer à vos projets pétroliers
nour et plus tranquillement polluer
l'air et les torrents et ce qui va se
passer vous
plus de français vont débarquer c'est
qu'on m'en foutrais merde encore faire
monter le prix de l'immobilier râle et
surtout square les plus forts les
profiteurs doivent des cachets
[Musique]
piquant le québec sera déserté
nous les francophones de belgique on a
juste une question pratique quand est ce
qu'on peut en ménagers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
i